This is the Chris Abraham Show.
Hey there.
It's season five, episode 40, I
think.
And if it's not, then I'm going
to make it episode 40 because I
have the power of control over
time and space with regards to
my podcast.
Yesterday was a bust, but I did
spend hours with a beautiful
South Sudanese former barista,
currently restaurant manager at
at Fresh Harvest or whatever
that restaurant is and looks
like it's going to rain today.
But yesterday, even the library
which is supposed to close at
8:00, even that son of a bitch
closed at 4:00 or before 4
because there was like threat of
crazy tropical storms and not
tropical storms, crazy
thunderstorms.
And the end is nigh kind of
tornadoes and everything.
Like literally the library,
which prides itself on staying
open during heat warnings and
stuff just so that it can take
care of, you know, hot people
even.
They completely wimped out and
closed early and put up signs
and and I went home and did I do
anything?
I ate some chicken and then I
got onto the erg.
That's right, I had committed
both here and on Fun slow and on
chrisabraham.com.
I committed to doing to getting
back on the rowing machine and
doing the dog days of summer
challenge and what that requires
is it's a four weeks challenge
that results in 100,000 meters.
Rd. the first week is 10,000
meters, the second week is
20,000 meters, the third week is
30,000 meters and the final week
is 40,000 meters.
So yesterday was the end of the
first week.
So I'm like, damn, I've got 7000
meters left and I just wasn't
into it.
So I did it though, got it done,
did like 10,124 meters in the
week, which usually I do in a
day, but this day at the last
week has been kind of Hibiji
Gibbs, you B GB.
So I finished it.
Now I am going to make sure that
I spend at least half an hour or
an hour every evening slow
rowing so that I can easily
knock the 20,000 meters out of
the way and then the 30 and then
the 40 and hopefully it'll again
turn into a 10,000 meters a day
habit.
Which I promised myself.
But as I told you before, I'm in
a constant active hot kinetic
war between I don't even know
what my ego does.
My ego is busy trying to be ego
less, but my ID and my superego
are in constant hot war with
each other.
And usually I make promises, not
six weeks but sometimes six
months earlier than I start
following through with them.
So the ERG has just been sitting
there.
I even bought an entire
superstructure for the ERG so
that I could affix my mini iPad
onto the onto the stand so that
I could have a even a bigger
display.
But none of that has happened
and the apartment is a mess.
The apartment is catastrophic.
Everything is grotesque, but all
that has driven me to being
outside all the time in active
denial of the catastroph.
So I am really excited about
becoming full body strong again.
I feel like the kind of exercise
that the Earth gives you is
completely and utterly different
than the kind of exercise that
walking and rucking does.
I'm not stopping walking.
I walk everywhere I go.
Like I said, I did take the 30
pound plate out of my bag, so
it's really nice.
It's really comfortable.
I had intended yesterday between
or after leaving the library.
I had expected and wanted to go
to Walter Reed Park to start my
suspension, training, workout
and all that.
But and I could have done right,
like instead of just leaving the
library and coming home, I could
have left the library and gone
to Starbucks and stayed there
till 8:30.
But I fell for the.
I fell for the grand conspiracy
that the that the world was
going to end under the hail of
hail and under the gods
thunderstorms and all that kind
of stuff.
And last thing I wanted to do
was be stuck in Starbucks during
an extreme long, like, radio
worthy kind of Hellfire that was
going to be promised.
So I went home.
I noodled around the TVA little
bit.
I ate chicken and I urged and I
saw some really like the latest,
the latest season of like
Mandalorians suck.
All those doofuses at the
Mandalorian camp and all the
doofus time with with Gogu
Gorgu, the baby Yoga and it's
slow and bad pacing.
And also that, like Invasion
series sucks and Obi 1 sucks and
Mando not Mando.
Aldor on Andor Andor sucks and
they all suck.
So this morning I've got to
watch the latest episode, the
semifinal of Detective Bake Off
or Project Investigative Baking.
I don't know what it's called,
but it's it's really good.
It's on Hulu and now I'm picking
up breakfast from Bob and
Edith's Diner, and I'm going to
make it 1 meal a day because
this is definitely not strict
carnivore.
So I'm going to hit pause and I
will be back once I retrieve the
food.
All right, so got the food.
Now I'm crossing the street over
to the Starbucks side of the
road.
Thank goddess that Adobe
invented a I audio fixing
because honestly, after I run it
through that and then run it
through normalizing compressor,
you know, using Audacity,
Audacity, it sounds like I'm
recording in a frickin studio
and it's incredible.
So I'm not even ever worried
about background noise anymore.
The truth is is though, as my
twin sister Linda Going told me
that the louder the background
noise gets, the louder I scream.
And the louder I scream, the
more frenetic I sound when, or
frantic or mad I sound when
everything is normalized.
That's because I'm screaming
over St. construction and
everything.
So I it basically puts me into
like a Alex Jones frame of
voice.
So listen, you can.
There's a there's like a diesel
truck that he sends it.
I don't even know.
It's really loud.
I don't even know if you guys
can hear that after the magic of
Adobe A I It's completely
cacophonous.
Man, I would never want to live
on this road because I love
always having windows open.
And to be honest, now that I've
been recording, like when I'm
not recording these things my my
my body naturally filters out
background noise.
So I don't even know how loud it
is, you know, normally.
But when I'm sensitive
recording, I hear every diesel
truck.
So good Lord, these beautiful
executive apartments like
Penrose Square and so forth seem
like they're awesome.
But could you imagine with the
with the V8 kids and with the
ricers and the motorcyclists and
the Harley guys and the No Pipes
gang and the glass packs and all
the diesel trucks and delivery
trucks and construction, Would
you imagine living in this
building?
And I would never open the
windows?
It'd be impossible.
It would create a kind, if you
will, of a PTSD, right?
It's completely maddening and I
wouldn't like that.
Anyway, Tonight I am going to,
I'm almost to where I'm going to
eat.
So tonight I am going to get as
many comfortable and easy meters
as I can into the pot so that
when the next seven days will
have passed I won't have to do a
lot of last minute catch up.
Although waiting till the last
minute to do all the work and
then staying up all night is how
I defined my entire college
career.
And it was so stupid and so
unnecessary.
And from little did I know that
like with the ADHD plus the A
Fantasia plus the S dam
completely undiagnosed ever I if
I had known all that well,
nothing would be different.
But I totally would take
advantage of the unfair
advantages that those things
would have brought me, like more
time taking the tests and all
kinds of other relatively unfair
benefits.
On that note, I will close off
season five, episode 40, and I
think I'm going to run it till
50 and then I'll move on to
season six.
I think that seasons are not
based on years, they're based
on.
Should it be 50 episodes or 100
episodes?
To all the people who do not
listen to me, please let me
know.
I will.
If I remember, I will put a poll
on the on the podcasts.
Take care, I love you and I'll
talk to you soon.
Bon appetit.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.